the coronavirus pandemic has now cost
more than one hundred thousand lives in
germany
the number of infections keeps rising
raising fears the worst is yet to come
[Music]
not since the second world war has
germany faced a challenge that so much
depends on our universal solidarity
as germany faces a deadly fourth wave
new restrictions and lockdowns may be on
their way
to keep more lives
from being lost
[Music]
hello and welcome to your covet 19
special i'm chris coburn berlin
with infection rates higher than ever
and the growing number of hospitals at
breaking point the german air force has
been airlifting icu patients to regions
with free beds many others are meanwhile
grieving over the lives that the
pandemic has already taken in germany dw
reporter louisa von richthofen spoke to
one woman who is mourning two close
relatives
my father was a fun-loving man very
cheerful and lively he didn't let
anything get him down he was not ready
to go even on the day that i visited him
at the icu i felt his love of life
father passed away almost a year ago
and that was the second heartbreaking
moment for her and her family
only a few days before her father-in-law
had passed away too
he was also a victim of covet 19.
during that time the entire family was
infected with the coronavirus
today kirsten flashter still wonders how
she found the strength to get through
those fateful weeks
that's my papadum
we were all in quarantine when my father
died and that was horrible
i could only talk to my mother over the
phone or leave her voice messages
each and every one of us suffered
after my father died i was not allowed
to see him his body was taken directly
from the hospital to the crematorium
and i miss that it is such an important
part of mourning
i still feel i need to see him in order
to fully understand why he had to die
this way i am literally missing the
stage of the grief process
it's not like claisha was a stranger to
morning it's actually her job
she is a grief counselor and more and
more people whose relatives have died
from covet 19 are coming to her
i think going through this myself has
made me more sensitive to what others
are going through i can say i feel for
you and really mean it i have a deeper
empathy when i hear their stories
[Music]
she has experienced firsthand much of
what these people are going through
many feel guilty because they could not
be there in person while their loved
ones were suffering
it is very important to me to see more
than just the final moments of death
instead i want to remember their whole
life story my connection to my father
and father-in-law and think about our
relationship
what memories do i have what was special
and i tried to communicate this way of
dealing with grief to those i comfort as
well
she still can't fathom the fact that
hundreds of people in germany die of
covet 19 every day
you experience your own life in a
different way when you realize that
other people are going through the same
things as you are
so many people are losing their loved
ones and you have to ask yourself does
it have to be this way
and i am worried when i think about this
i hope that every individual will also
take responsibility for society as a
whole
that they will act responsibly so that
we can fight against the fourth wave and
get control of the situation
the pandemic is a long way from being
over
so far more than one hundred thousand
people have died in germany
but the number of people who live in
grief goes uncounted
let's take a closer look at this figure
and what it means with tobias court
director of the institute of public
health at berlin's charity hospital
welcome to the program 100 000 covet 19
deaths in germany what does this number
tell us when it comes to the country's
approach to the pandemic
well first of all it's a symbolic number
and as we just heard behind every case
there are families there are friends who
are suffering
it should remind us how deadly this
virus can be and and is and it should
remind us that we definitely have to
take measures to really prevent future
deaths from this disease
and if we
put this number into a international
context where does germany find itself
there
i think it's very difficult to compare
countries as to cultural differences
differences in availability of vaccines
vaccine rates etc it's definitely too
high and we really need to understand
how
serious this disease is
now obviously a medical crisis of these
proportions will cause suffering and
will have victims nevertheless how many
of these 100 000 deaths
would have been avoidable
it's a good question it's very difficult
to precisely estimate many many of those
certainly could have been avoided
specifically after we had vaccinations
and now the the real issue is that we
should
um understand that we can avoid future
deaths if we pick up the vaccination
rate if we take some measures to really
get the numbers down because many more
unfortunately will die in the future
germany does have a vaccination rate
below 70
uh below the eu average that certainly
seems to play a role here now let's look
at the current situation much is not yet
clear when it comes to the newly
discovered omicron variant how do you
expect it to impact the course of the
pandemic in this country
it's very difficult to estimate at this
point as we do not have all the numbers
that we need to make proper estimation
certainly it's of concern in particular
if you have a situation right now where
you have high number of new cases every
day where the hospitals are full and the
society is really um on its edge so we
need to make sure that the numbers are
going down now should omicron really
have the impact that we all fear
when the delta variant first was
discovered there were experts saying
well it might be more infectious
but less lethal is that something that
could apply to the omicron variant as
well
i think this is speculation right now we
know for sure omicron is here in germany
already probably has been here for
several weeks and there's a certain
concern that this variant will take over
as delta took over a few months ago
whether this is more severe or more
deadly is something that we need to
carefully evaluate
when the world health organization warns
that omicron may have a high likelihood
of immune escape from antibody mediated
protection what does that mean
it means that the vaccines may not be as
effective as against the delta variant
or the vile variant that we had in in
the beginning so we definitely need to
make sure that we understand that these
may come up do we need to get vaccinated
we need to get the booster shots it's
really important now to watch the
situation and to collect data to uh then
make proper uh consequences for on the
population level
tobias as people are arriving on flights
from south africa and neighboring
countries and they're sent to quarantine
because of the omicron variant what
progress have we made when it comes to
containing the virus through such
surveillance
i think first of all it's important that
this is not a south african problem
south africa was able to detect this
variant and shows the
really good surveillance system that
they have omicron certainly is in other
regions of the world already
but also it shows that the international
community
has learned and has taken action quickly
to really react to this whether the
action is enough or or proper is
something that we have to evaluate daily
to not making these regions in the world
or specifically south africa suffering
more than necessary
now if we look at the situation here in
germany there are some experts saying
that another hundred thousand people
will die of covet 19 in germany before
this whole pandemic will be over you
yourself are skeptical as well how
reliable is such a figure and what does
it depend on
not to happen for that matter
well those figures come from
mathematical models that project into
the future those models depend strongly
on assumptions so if we all get
vaccinated if we all get a booster shot
and in the future there will be modified
vaccinations available this number
hopefully will not be reality however
there are certain scenarios where this
number may in fact be reality so we
definitely have to be on alert and
evaluate the situation very carefully
today and in the future
tobias court director of the institute
of public health at berlin's charity
hospital thank you for talking to us
thank you for having me
dying of covet 19 has been the sad fate
of millions of people around the world
but many
more have fallen ill and survived and
that is one issue that one of your
questions for our science correspondent
derek williams touches on
[Music]
what's the survival rate of kovit 19 how
is it calculated
scientists who work with data on
mortality rates related to covet 19 they
generally don't use the term
survival rate although it is a common
one in evaluating other diseases like
cancer for example
according to cancer.net
the five-year survival rate for
pancreatic cancer
is 10 percent that's the percentage of
people who are diagnosed with it who are
still living at the end of those five
years
but epidemiologists dealing with a
pandemic disease where large numbers of
people also recover
they generally talk instead about other
numbers especially what's called
the case fatality rate or the cfr now
it's calculated
by dividing the number of confirmed
deaths from the disease
by the number of people diagnosed with
it by a test so clear background numbers
as this graphic from our world and data
shows cfrs have generally fallen in most
countries over time
from the early days of the pandemic that
mostly reflects the fact that doctors
have gotten a lot better at treating the
disease since it first appeared
in germany this credible source says
that at the moment
the cfr is around 1.8 percent now
that doesn't sound like much but think
about it for a second if correct
it means covid19 is currently killing
about 18
out of every thousand people diagnosed
with it here which makes it about 10
times more lethal than seasonal flu
and when you have tens of thousands of
people being newly diagnosed every day
like at the moment in germany
the numbers of those dying from it will
start to add up
very fast
very soon of course
most people who get the disease will
survive it but that's also highly
dependent the experts say
on factors like your own personal age
and your health and whether you've been
vaccinated so
talking about general survival rates and
trying to apply the concept to predict
your own chances of survival if you're
infected
doesn't really make sense
[Music]